that all possible realities actually exist.
Also, a younger physicist, Max Tegmark,
who believes that all mathematical structures exist,
and mathematical existence is the same thing
as physical existence,
so we have this vastly rich multiverse
that encompasses every logical possibility.
Now, in taking this metaphysical way out,
these physicists and also philosophers are actually
reaching back to a very old idea
that goes back to Plato.
It's the principle of plenitude or fecundity,
or the great chain of being,
that reality is actually as full as possible.
It's as far removed from nothingness
as it could possibly be.
So we have these two extremes now.
We have sheer nothingness on one side,
and we have this vision of a reality
that encompasses every conceivable world
at the other extreme: the fullest possible reality,
nothingness, the simplest possible reality.
Now what's in between these two extremes?
There are all kinds of intermediate realities
that include some things and leave out others.
So one of these intermediate realities
is, say, the most mathematically elegant reality,
that leaves out the inelegant bits,
the ugly asymmetries and so forth.
Now, there are some physicists who will tell you
that we're actually living in the most elegant reality.
I think that Brian Greene is in the audience,
and he has written a book called "The Elegant Universe."
He claims that the universe we live in mathematically
is very elegant.
Don't believe him. (Laughter)
It's a pious hope, I wish it were true,
but I think the other day he admitted to me
it's really an ugly universe.
It's stupidly constructed,
it's got way too many arbitrary coupling constants
and mass ratios
and superfluous families of elementary particles,
and what the hell is dark energy?
It's a stick and bubble gum contraption.
It's not an elegant universe. (Laughter)
And then there's the best of all possible worlds
in an ethical sense.
You should get solemn now,
because a world in which sentient beings
don't suffer needlessly,
in which there aren't things like
childhood cancer or the Holocaust.
This is an ethical conception.
Anyway, so between nothingness
and the fullest possible reality,
various special realities.
Nothingness is special. It's the simplest.
Then there's the most elegant possible reality.
That's special.
The fullest possible reality, that's special.
But what are we leaving out here?
There's also just the crummy,
generic realities
that aren't special in any way,
that are sort of random.
They're infinitely removed from nothingness,
but they fall infinitely short of complete fullness.
They're a mixture of chaos and order,
of mathematical elegance and ugliness.
So I would describe these realities
as an infinite, mediocre, incomplete mess,
a generic reality, a kind of cosmic junk shot.
And these realities,
is there a deity in any of these realities?
Maybe, but the deity isn't perfect
like the Judeo-Christian deity.
The deity isn't all-good and all-powerful.
It might be instead 100 percent malevolent
but only 80 percent effective,
which pretty much describes the world we see around us, I think. (Laughter)
So I would like to propose that the resolution
to the mystery of existence
is that the reality we exist in
is one of these generic realities.
Reality has to turn out some way.
It can either turn out to be nothing
or everything or something in between.
So if it has some special feature,
like being really elegant or really full
or really simple, like nothingness,
that would require an explanation.
But if it's just one of these random, generic realities,
there's no further explanation for it.
And indeed, I would say
that's the reality we live in.
That's what science is telling us.
At the beginning of the week,
we got the exciting information that
the theory of inflation, which predicts a big,
infinite, messy, arbitrary, pointless reality,
it's like a big frothing champagne
coming out of a bottle endlessly,
a vast universe, mostly a wasteland
with little pockets of charm and order and peace,
this has been confirmed,
this inflationary scenario, by the observations
made by radio telescopes in Antarctica
that looked at the signature of the gravitational waves
from just before the Big Bang.
I'm sure you all know about this.
So anyway, I think there's some evidence
that this really is the reality that we're stuck with.
Now, why should you care?
Well — (Laughter) —
the question, "Why does the world exist?"
that's the cosmic question, it sort of rhymes
with a more intimate question:
Why do I exist? Why do you exist?
you know, our existence would seem to be amazingly improbable,
because there's an enormous number of genetically possible humans,
if you can compute it by looking at
the number of the genes and the number of alleles and so forth,
and a back-of-the-envelope calculation will tell you
there are about 10 to the 10,000th
possible humans, genetically.
That's between a googol and a googolplex.
And the number of the actual humans that have existed
is 100 billion, maybe 50 billion,
an infinitesimal fraction, so all of us,
we've won this amazing cosmic lottery.
We're here. Okay.
So what kind of reality do we want to live in?
Do we want to live in a special reality?
What if we were living in the most elegant possible reality?
Imagine the existential pressure on us
to live up to that, to be elegant,
not to pull down the tone of it.
Or, what if we were living in the fullest possible reality?
Well then our existence would be guaranteed,
because every possible thing
exists in that reality,
but our choices would be meaningless.
If I really struggle morally and agonize
and I decide to do the right thing,
what difference does it make,
because there are an infinite number
of versions of me
also doing the right thing
and an infinite number doing the wrong thing.
So my choices are meaningless.
So we don't want to live in that special reality.
And as for the special reality of nothingness,
we wouldn't be having this conversation.
So I think living in a generic reality that's mediocre,
there are nasty bits and nice bits
and we could make the nice bits bigger
and the nasty bits smaller
and that gives us a kind of purpose in life.
The universe is absurd,
but we can still construct a purpose,
and that's a pretty good one,
and the overall mediocrity of reality
kind of resonates nicely with the mediocrity
we all feel in the core of our being.
And I know you feel it.
I know you're all special,
but you're still kind of secretly mediocre,
don't you think?
(Laughter) (Applause)
So anyway, you may say, this puzzle, the mystery of existence,
it's just silly mystery-mongering.
You're not astonished at the existence of the universe
and you're in good company.
Bertrand Russell said,
"I should say the universe is just there, and that's all."
Just a brute fact.
And my professor at Columbia, Sidney Morgenbesser,
a great philosophical wag,
when I said to him, "Professor Morgenbesser,
why is there something rather than nothing?"
And he said, "Oh, even if there was nothing,
you still wouldn't be satisfied."
So — (Laughter) — okay.
So you're not astonished. I don't care.
But I will tell you something to conclude
that I guarantee you will astonish you,
because it's astonished all of the brilliant,
wonderful people I've met at this TED conference,
when I've told them, and it's this:
Never in my life have I had a cell phone.
Thank you.
(Laughter) (Applause)